so I was practicing a lot and writing a
book and training for all these ultra
distance events that none of which was
really generating any money you know but
still couldn't see the path forward
there was no template for how to do that
it was really just showing up every day
trying to pay attention what can I do
and it was being in it was just being in
service like what can I offer well I'll
write this blog post or I'll go give
this talk or I'll go do this the podcast
I began I did it for two years before I
made a single dollar I didn't start it
as a thinking it was going to be some
kind of professional Enterprise it was
just something I felt strongly about I
felt called to do if you've done the
internal work to really know yourself
and what you're passionate about and you
can if you can have the courage and the
faith to step into that that indeed the
universe will conspire to support you
and you will find your way and it
doesn't mean that it's going to work out
the way that you want it to work out or
think that it's going to work out but by
remaining steadfast
that that is how I was able to see it
through